normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government when
you search for the story about the fist
fight that nearly occurred in the senate
in a senate hearing most headlines are
like Bernie Sanders stops fist fight and
he did and I am upset with Bernie okay
okay I'm not really you know that you
shouldn't fight in the Senate but here's
the story Senator Mullins challenges
Teamsters president to fight during
Committee hearing Senator Mark way
Mullen a republican challenge team
president Shan O'Brien to a fight during
a senate committee on health education
labor and pensions Committee hearing on
Tuesday I I really would love to get
Senator Mullen on the show now because
this was just like absolutely epic and
uh let me so sha M O'Brien has been
making fun of Mullins he tweeted greedy
CEO who pretends like he self-made in
reality just a clown and fraud always
has been always will be quit the tough
guy act in these Senate hearings you
know where to find me any place anytime
Cowboy # little man syndrome and there's
a a photo of him standing on a box
during a debate or something like this
and uh you know what I I'm I'm just
going to I'm going to I'm going to play
the video for you guys and uh you can
listen for yourselves like he's
self-made sir I wish he was in the truck
with me when I was building my plumbing
company myself and my wife was running
the office because I sure remember
working pretty hard in long hours
pretends like he's self-made what a
clown fraud
always has been always will be quit the
tough guy act in these Senate hearings
you know where to find me any place
anytime
Cowboy sir this is a time this is a
place you want to run your mouth we can
be to consenting adults we can finish it
here okay that's fine do it now I'd love
to do it right now well stand your butt
up then you stand your up butt up oh
hold
stop go for theing sit down sit down
okay you know you're a United States
Senator sit down please all right very
hold it hold
it if we can no I have the I'm sorry
this is he you'll have your time okay
can I respond oh no you
can't
hearing oh wow in our official
government record like okay but my
question is does this happen more or
less often now that there are cameras
televising this than in the past well
there was that Democrat who just
announced he's retiring and one of his
big CRI Peaks was that Congress is
performative that everyone's just
looking have their viral moment but what
I like about this and I did confirm this
just now uh is that Mullins is in fact a
former undefeated MMA champion no wait
what on his official bio on the Senate
Mark Wayne Mullins is a former
undefeated mixed martial arts MMA
fighter with a professional record of 5
and0 so I'm just he ready he was
inducted into the Oklahoma Wrestling
Hall of Fame in 2016 so I'm telling you
this would have been amazing wow man wow
i' I'd like I would love to get him on
maybe a culture War episode likey you
got to get him and the teamster though
no they'll fight exactly it's not it's
not really a culture War episode I'm
just saying like some sort of Logan Paul
boxing match yeah that's who needs to
reach out to them Logan Paul what are
you doing here team I I just I I just
got I gotta say let's be real okay
here's Mr O'Brien yo this this dude
would get rocked by moments yeah get
push he push him and then he'd get
choked no this this guy probably
wouldn't last 5 seconds he he probably
put him in a choke really fast or like
an arm bar or something who's older I
I'm assuming he's older it looks like
him but I'm not sure he might have an
ill look this guy
face this guy who's this so into it
who's this guy what is this he's
probably anban who is like let's go this
is what it came here for I just you know
that Meme where it's like the two women
are like and they cover their mouths and
the guy just smiles yeah like I imagine
a lot of the guys in there watching this
Haven started laughing like let's go the
Bernie Bernie like really came off as a
badass except if he was bigger and
stronger than the other dudes I would
have been
like he is like the high school teacher
coming out into the hallway being like
everybody go go to your rooms this isn't
okay killing the fun and I think I mean
Mark Wayne Mullins is interesting to me
because he's one of the only Tradesmen
who own who has a seat in the Senate
right and actually theoretically Bernie
Sanders also lists himself as a former
Carpenter and so we have Tradesman V
Tradesman V Teamster which I
interesting do you think that was a
planned moment or is just a moment of
passion calling I think he went in
knowing he would threaten to fight him I
just don't he was expecting a response
of like yes I will fight you right now
so here's a tweet from citizen Free
Press update Mullen posts a picture with
his guns and challenges Teamster boss
Shawn O'Brien to a fight duel cuz he's
got he says let's do it any place
anytime and then he tagged comfortably
smug in it comfortably smug said this is
an imit for Senator Mullen to come on
ruthless podcast oh okay he's not's not
threatening to duel him right okay
citizen free is wrong he's responding to
the podcast saying he's going to go on
to podcast oh hey Senator Mullins we'd
love to have you on we we definitely got
to talk about this yeah be fantastic
Let's Make A Make Some Noise about the
challenge do you think that watching
dude's fight makes culture become more
combative or is it like an outlet or do
you think that we should see people
fight because then we know that there
are correct times to channel aggression
instead of just letting people be
weirdly aggresses forever until they
default into extreme violence right
because we're seeing less violence from
our at least elected officials than ever
but at the same time I feel like we're
more in terms of rhetoric and division
like we've gone further to the extreme
so maybe it's we're actually lacking the
consequences that comes from this
rhetoric that would naturally kind of
pull people back maybe we do need to see
that oh yeah words have consequences you
can't just mouth off and expect nothing
to happen like people eventually will
call you out and some people like Mullen
they might be willing to go to blow yeah
I always heard the big difference
between men and women with is that women
are sort of pass aggressive they hold
grudges forever but also they are not
prone to violence whereas men if they
have a conflict ultimately it always
could come to like hitting each other
but then at that point you've decided
who's sort of in charge so you can
almost move past it often yelling with
like two guys guy friends will like yell
at each other I don't do it as much
anymore but like growing up it'd be like
you'd scream it out and then you'd be
done and then it'd be totally back to
normal the next day yeah yeah very
different from women yeah women would
hold on to that for the rest of their
lives they see each other but they'd
hate each other yeah he's the only
current he's the only currently serving
Senator without at least a bachelor's
degree wow he's super cool he also is
like an active I think he uh I don't
know what the term is but he like
ranches he raises cows and stuff like he
is an interesting he's a real cowboy MMA
fighter yeah I was working on this piece
for a long time where I was like
stalking all the professional
backgrounds of everyone in the Senate
and um he's really unique right there
are Senators that literally own uh MLB
teams and there's this guy who has a big
family and is actually a Tradesman who
built his company and then made to US
Senate like why don't we have more
people like that he's super rich uh
let's see it says between November 06
and april7 Mullen fought in three MMA
fights winning all three his total fight
time was less than 10 minutes and he
fought a total of less than three full
rounds that's the way to win
wow mess that dude up yeah also he
should now fight every other American
Senator aot not the women but like that
would be fascinating right well why not
you know what's
gender yeah exactly instead of this uh
voting for our uh speaker of the house
we just have them fight like Waka that's
how we should decide political
leadership yeah what is it patriarchal
Bloodlines in in ritual combat uh Mark
Wayne Mullen I want to I want to make
sure everybody on say he did not start
the fight that dude threatened him on
Twitter and then and then imagine I mean
dude you're you're you're like I'm here
to do my job and this guy's posting that
he wants to fight me that he's going to
fight me and then he's going to show up
to where I'm working and have to testify
before me I'm going to call him out for
it I respect it yeah and uh I I as much
as I think uh all of the men listening
are like oh Bernie what are you doing
okay Bernie we we the the responsible
portions of the male brain are saying I
know it was the you should stop the
fight nobody wants to get it but you
know the the the the more primate part
of the brain is screaming berie no yeah
it was um it was I mean it would have
set a precedent of that fighting in
there is okay if they'd fought but I
think they if they both agreed to it
then why wouldn't we allow a gentleman's
duel well that's the thing mutual combat
is legal in lot of places I don't know
if it's legal in DC let me check
actually I think in Oregon mutual combat
there's no crime if two people agree to
fight D that guy that ball dude was
going to get rocked he had no idea he
was talking crap dude that's people that
haven't gotten hit or been in a fight
before they're always think they're
going to win a situation like that they
think a little bit bigger than them it's
not always how it works man well he knew
someone would intervene I just you know
could you imagine this guy waking up in
the morning and be like Bernie Sanders
is going to intervene on my behalf don't
have to fight my only only it's not
orgon Washington State and Texas have
mutual combat laws uh both both parties
must agree to the fight it must be in
public and there can be no serious
bodily injury to the partic uh to the
par uh to the participants but how do
they distinguish between that and
something like UFC like because you
could do UFC in Las Vegas I mean isn't
that technically a mutually agreed upon
fight I think they're called sanctioned
fights I could be sanctioned something
about like they get permits for these
fights to happen and everybody knows
that like you know the best MMA fights
are after the fight's over the dudes T
touch gloves give a hug and then go like
they know that they're they don't hate
each other they're trying to be the best
fighter that I love watching that I
can't stand the snoody MMA fighters who
are like smack talking and I'm like I
get it they're trying to like get
attention and build ratings or whatever
but I like the fights when a dude loses
and the other guy like gives him a fist
Bunch they shake hands or whatever well
my husband he's really into UFC he
watches it like B basically any Saturday
that there's a fight but he was saying
that the re there's an incentive for for
them to trash talk and try to make it as
toxic as possible because then it draws
viewers and then like their bags bigger
and there's just more attention on them
exactly exactly you you want people to
you you want people to hope you lose
yeah then more money comes in everybody
wants to watch because they're looking
for the villain and it's like yeah you
know whatever that happened with that
Logan Paul fight recently that some guy
was like talking about his his
ex-girlfriend or his wife I don't even
want to propagate the nonsense but Logan
went in there and decimated the dude
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net